as we try to learn a little bit more
about what's going on with Ezekiel
Elliott temporary restraining order you
filed the Eastern District taxes pretty
and Michael McCann
si si our senior legal analyst joins us
here on the show so Mike take me through
this why why did Elliot filed this
appeal ahead of Harold Henderson's
ruling Chris I think he did that to get
a court that he thinks was better for
him than if the NFL files first because
Elliot and his legal team know that back
during deflategate right after Roger
Goodell issued his decision upholding
his own suspension of Brady the NFL
rushed to court in New York and
ultimately of course won there that case
is now precedent so Elliot and his legal
team really want to avoid New York and
so they filed in Texas I don't know if
Texas is necessarily a better form
because the precedent and that
jurisdiction isn't necessarily favorable
to him but he knows he's gonna lose in
New York so I think that was the
thinking behind this okay now that he's
filed how do you see the NFL responding
I think the NFL will one try to move the
case to New York
that's a procedural step and then
secondly they'll argue that his
arguments really are not legally
meaningful the NFL will argue that even
if the process wasn't great used to
judge Ezekiel Elliott article 46 of the
CBA gives Roger Goodell and by extension
anyone he picks to hear an arbitration
hearing with enormous latitude in
deciding what a punishment is so it's a
it's a hard place to be in for Ezekiel
Elias lawyers he has excellent lawyers
Jeffrey Kessler is a terrific lawyer I
know he didn't win the Brady case and he
didn't win Peterson but he won parts of
those cases and he has to deal with a
legal document that's really disfavor
about two players mention the Tom Brady
lost his case does the Brady case offer
any kind of roadmap for how this could
go how long it could take yeah I mean if
it takes the path that the Brady case
took we're looking at at a minimum of
six months and perhaps longer than that
now Elliot is also going to file a
petition for a temporary restraining
order which if granted would allow him
to play but they are seldom granted him
maybe he'll get one but they're really
hard to show because he has to show
among other things that he has a high
likelihood of success that he'll suffer
irreparable harm they're going to try
everything they can there's no question
about it
but none of these fights are necessarily
favored because at the end of the day
Roger Goodell
and by extension anyone he picks has
tremendous power best guess Mike if
Harold Henderson up holds it all or a
portion of this suspension is Ezekiel
Elliott on the field for week one I mean
the odds are no if we look at precedent
if we look at what the law tells us the
odds are that Elliott will be suspended
for week one and it's going to be hard
for him to overcome that is it
impossible no and we never know if he
gets the right judge and there all sorts
of things that can play out but the odds
aren't good for him but this is a
different jurisdiction so he certainly
can't have any worse of a time there
than he would have in New York Michael
McKean si legal analyst joining us here
on the Dan Patrick Oh Mike is I'm as I'm
reading through a summary of all this
and of course this is just breaking this
morning one of the things that stands
out is that in this filing this alleged
testimony by Kia right Roberts the NFL's
director investigations who apparently
testified that she was the only NFL
employee interviewed Tiffany Thompson
that she would not have recommended
discipline for Elliott based on what she
found did that stand out to you at all
yeah it certainly stands out if we look
at it and say if anyone's looking at
this from a neutral perspective we would
say that's pretty important that the one
person who interviewed the accuser
didn't believe that it warranted a
punishment for Elliott on the other hand
I think you know I hate to say it but
legally I'm not sure that matters
because under article 46 it's Goodell is
call as to what is the punishment and he
could have reached that decision on also
for all sorts of reasons so it's
meaningful from the standpoint of common
sense for public relations I'm not sure
if the
attaches the same level of meaning does
the fact that Elliot was never charged
with a crime or there's never any
adjudication help him at all in these
proceedings not really the fact of
Goodell doesn't need a criminal charge
to punish a player
I think it's meaningful in the sense
that it suggests that the case against
him isn't as strong as some believe but
it but in terms of does it authorize the
punishment does it impact whether or not
a punishment should be upheld on appeal
the answer to that is no speculate for
me here a bit Mike my issue with a lot
of this is that the NFL is acting as
investigator judge and jury on an
instant and an alleged crime that
effectively brands a guy for the rest of
his life I mean if this goes through in
Ezekiel it is suspended for multiple
games it'll always be a footnote in his
his life his career that he's been
branded a domestic abuser do you have
any problem with the NFL despite the
fact they did do a thorough
investigation conducting this process
the way that they did it I think the NFL
has the worst system for player conduct
matters if we look at the other lis I
mean just look at the NBA does the NBA
ever have anything like this the NBA
avoids right I mean it's a totally
different dynamic dynamic in the NBA
it's almost as if in the NFL there is an
invitation to have a legal fight over a
player suspension so I don't think this
is a good system at all I think a better
system would have someone neutral if a
suspension is after a certain length but
that's not what the players agree to and
at the end of the day there's a contract
and that contract is the collective
bargaining agreement and until it's
changed I don't see this type of dynamic
going away expand on that a little bit
Mike how different is the NBA's process
than the NFL isn't something like this
well what is from what we know
informally the NBA and Players
Association have a much better
relationship on all sorts of levels but
including on matters of player
discipline that they communicate with
each other that there's some degree of
trust that I don't think exists with the
NFL and Players Association and the
secondarily if a player suspension in
the NBA is more than 12 games there's a
right to an independent or
traitor there's no right to an
independent arbitrator in the NFL so
here if we say let's say in the NFL if a
punishment is more than two games
suspension the player has a right to
have someone neutral here the appeal I
think that would be a much better system
than what exists that would lend
credibility that would ensure that any
serious player punishments are heard by
someone neutral and then the player
can't say he didn't get a fair shake hey
great to visit you Mike great stuff I
appreciate the time thanks Chris take up
it's michael mccann the SI legal analyst
joining us here on the Dan Patrick show
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience